this week we got foot pelo dancing horse
and combo Obama Obama Obama Obama so for
the first story this is grass vehicle
gay all right say something say
something sad sad like oh this guy's got
his foot amputated and got you side of
the pillow and he's using his foot as a
pillow
he isn't you I mean he is using it but
he didn't put it there so the hospital
that's disgusting why did the hospital
do that get right out of pillows no cuz
they just weren't treating on it this is
a case of neglect oh my god where is
this country India hmm I thought the guy
at the patient was just funny long as I
check this out look how funny I am I
could use my foot yeah legitimate I
thought he was doing the joke he goes
hey you want to see something very funny
yeah oh my god I'm telling them that
he's uncomfortable you learn because
he's got a bag of chips next to his head
and a bottle of water
we got size 18 feet my god did he know
that it was his own foot yeah
he knew the whole time he's laying there
so he's looking at the ceilings like my
foot got cut off and my foot is my own
pillow but he knew that why leave a bear
one like like that why isn't there blood
and like didn't they advocate it because
there's something wrong with it
so why put it next to his face it got
amputated because of a car accident and
so when he was getting wheeled into the
hospital you're just like I said yeah he
was just really uncomfortable he wanted
a pillow
finally like someone just came over and
just used a bomb his foot that is
[ __ ] inhumane pillow how about these
you don't what you don't know is that he
could have been a [ __ ] dick like give
me a [ __ ] you [ __ ] tired of the one
here [ __ ] user [ __ ] foot as a
pelicans gonna been a dick about it I
don't know when you're in that kind of
pain you're allowed to be a dick yeah I
I would give it a pat how much you want
to bet he was trying to run over a small
family though yeah in India right it's
like it's you
the punishment fits the crime yep who
knows what this cat did that's great
yeah you kick somebody in the face so
I'm gonna keep your foot by your face I
don't know who was at fault but here's
the school bus conductor and so they're
saying that when they guard they call
that our driver we get it we get it she
[ __ ] has a school bus and he's like
I like it when they make normal jobs so
sounds so cool I'm a trained technician
you know actually that sanitation yeah I
love all that yeah like selling myself a
CEO CEO we're called art technicians at
Target it's like I'm a CEO of a clothing
company that nobody's heard of yep well
I've heard of your clothes oh thanks
yeah well no we're talking about someone
who has probably like a teespring
website and ten shirts on their website
whole accident 25 schoolchildren were
hurt oh I think people are making up
their little own stories because this is
what happened okay so a nurse said oh we
can't have you forget where your feet is
so they put it on his neck so then you
know no one would go what's this foot
doing here and then walk away with it
right it's like this foots for this guy
yeah okay you know when I had knee
surgery they had a right like operate
this knee because stuff like that
happened cuz they'll operate the other
needs yeah yeah you had knee surgery
I mean you I knew you you knew we were
on crutches together yeah damn I really
don't care about you oh yeah did you
like skateboard or some [ __ ]
uh-uh no I had a torn meniscus from
volleyball and then I tore it more when
I was playing basketball with you guys
oh I remember it wasn't like an open
thing it was like great it was very
minimal they went inside and I cut the
cartilage yeah we call that laparoscopic
or whatever it was out there when you
got her yes I'll remember that [ __ ] you
do care about me [ __ ] you David that's
right I do remember the crutches cuz we
played with that [ __ ] yes yeah but I
don't remember you getting hurt I
remember you guys gonna go see the Dark
Knight around that time yep how are you
at taking pain can you take pain she
gave birth okay you can't take no pain
then she can't you know man no pain not
really so yesterday yesterday you know
girls biologically it can take more pain
way more than guys yep
okay we're [ __ ] bad I think I think
that's probably true but baby Nikki's
maybe out of that threshold no I think
it's just because she knows that you
give her love and caring that [ __ ] just
kind of gives you a little more
you think she faked it no not at all we
don't think anything she's faking it
no we don't think anything I think she
has Dave man maybe so yesterday I wake
up to her screening for the other room i
well first I heard a bunch of banging
that started to wake me up and then I
hear her screaming from the other room
and I run in and Nicki's on the ground
clutching her like her like shin because
she had been using like like we have
this like chest she'd been using it to
like just do stairs on and usually she
says use it and she slipped and hit her
shin on the edge of the thing and fell
forward
that's [ __ ] brutal yeah it's pretty
brutal bud but then I checked up the
laceration wasn't that bad it's fine it
hurts but she was crying for like 10
minutes or so no that one's tough would
you bleeding like a mofo no did it
scrape her skin off yeah a little bit
yeah that was yeah really
he'll have a scar to lose date like it
carved a chunk out of my shin it was so
gross that shit's painful though I don't
like that that's why I don't do box
jumps I just jump in the hair you see
but because you ran so she loves that
she can be vulnerable with you but like
Bart would be like babe are you okay
from the other room oh really yes I
think I just have to suck it the [ __ ] up
or you'll send me a text
hey I heard something upstairs or you
get it you get a FaceTime for her it
starts to ring in no not even a few time
she gets a Pegasus shut the [ __ ] up
waking up tyka fine there's nobody in
the whole world I'll take a FaceTime
from look I see the face I'm think I'm
up and I'm like no no it's fun I don't
like it why I just don't like it I just
I'm not ready for it ever I think I
think I'm not ready what if someone
preps you yo are you ready to feast on
it to give me a warning or something I
like FaceTime only if it's like somebody
haven't seen in a long time or we're not
gonna see each other in a minute yeah
but if I see you on a regular basis and
then you try to FaceTime me I might
listen here as they would say back in
the 90s and I've well true don't do that
like I know a specific guy that you guys
know when space time came out he always
wanted to FaceTime and I'm like dude
this is [ __ ] ridiculous yeah FaceTime
is only used when you
mutually masturbate with your
significant other because that's the
only time I use FaceTime is to watch
Jess masturbate I didn't laugh because I
actually really believe you I really I
don't use it for anything else I believe
that's why that's what I'm saying that's
what we're all like ya know the funniest
part of that is the fact that they live
together best history gave me idea
though what we'll see idea I'm gonna do
it oh okay I was like why why should you
just cuz you live together why should
you stop doing it cuz you guys get in
front of each other it's not the same
didn't love is always better love that's
true you guys should just lock your
doors so you can't escape either was it
always that like shitty lighting thing
to you know how when you're watching
those cam video there's a magic to that
too yeah the pixilated yeah yeah kind of
Lord looks a little blue and purple kind
of voyeuristic what if it stops like on
a weird angle like poor connection and
it's just like yeah you know what maybe
I should just get a drill and drill a
little hole in the door and I just
[ __ ] people like this a true Japanese
man no one knew for like the longest
time because there's so many clues wait
nobody knew what that all Japanese I
mean it's like duh there's so many clues
the only thing that I don't do is sniff
dirty underwear yeah right you swear
yeah I swear I like I don't know if I
believe I like clean underwear all right
for our next story it's a matter of
principles there was this glove in Miami
that thought it was a great idea to have
a live horse genius so I'm gonna show
you guys a clip of their horse I get it
it's very competitive
oh yeah me man really
what's the flyer say is it life or
Sneijder what's it stupid but I'm saying
I can understand why they think they
have to like out level the other I'll do
it
what's the name of the club I would have
put a [ __ ] horn on top of that horse
a bit like unicorn Knight makes more
sense
[ __ ] Enchanted Forest night yeah
that's it the name of the club is Mokai
lounge in Miami Beach what is mo
climbing horse you know what's sad
though I hope it was a deaf horse cuz
the [ __ ] basin that horse freaked out
as soon as they brought him out so
that's why I'm like come on you didn't
think I'm surprised that did the horse
kick somebody in the chest I'm an issue
alright why didn't they find a dead
horse and horses and [ __ ] yeah they
should all they're a mega girl god
there's a go-go dancer
I know it's actually Jean right now oh
it's Bucky oh he's biting people [ __ ]
out here why are people cheering because
I watch it probably it's kinda like one
of the Tom breaks a dish it's like
you're kind of like oh oh we do well
that's the thing to do in a restaurant
when somebody breaks the cup yeah once
this video went up it went viral and
then immediately they got there the
club's business like it's taken away the
business licenses oh my god but is it
the club's fault though because you know
the way that it's ran is different party
promotion groups rent the club out for
the weekend and then they throw the
event and then people who own the real
estate just kind of rent it out well
what they've done this in the past so
then they're [ __ ] idiots
they're like shock jocks like but in
club form yeah this is like the Logan
Paul of [ __ ] clubs so a lot of people
are pissed when they saw this because
they're just like how are you gonna like
stay off the animal cruelty if you're
trying to like have a crazy event so
they should have brought earmuffs for
the horse I think so but don't they
freak out just by the clothes like close
proximity of a lot of people
we gotta find horses out are like very
very intimate I love that this is wrong
but it and but if you serve horse meat
in the club that's totally fine horse
tacos tacos are what really you can't
you can't you can't illegal here in
America yes it's a leland t-shirt yeah
yeah to eat yeah but I think they
slaughter them here oh yeah I think they
do kill them here and they send it to
other places so [ __ ] we're head eat
horses anywhere in America I don't think
so
why really because oh no I had it in
Japan my bad yeah I never have horse
meat I think that's how we looked it up
or you look Parsa me it's [ __ ] bomb
yes illegal it's illegal in the US it's
super no nevermind super lean but it's
still juicy and it's like sweet a little
bit yeah has a great flavor what did you
guys eat it with some pepper it was it
was Japanese barbecue so that yakiniku
we should vote out to international
waters and try something they eat it
like it like [ __ ] those Nordic
countries too yeah what was crazy
um what I thought was like a rare exotic
meat or whatever in Japan when I started
looking it up because I felt kind of
weird about him I'm a horse am I
supposed to eat horse for no reason back
in the day we used to eat just as
population like the general population
of the world we used to eat way more
horse than cows way more so that makes
sense because there were more horse than
cows like all over yeah so it's not
eating cows like a new thing and if
that's actually was weird back in the
day let me tell you a little bit history
about Genghis Khan you know those guys
they [ __ ] rode horseback and raided
towns right but they also [ __ ] ate the
horse drink horse milk made [ __ ]
alcohol out of their horse milk and and
so they would ride in this [ __ ] battle
but then like in long trips when they
get hungry they just [ __ ] kill their
own horse and eat it I like them too
they used everything I respect that
about genders huh like the horse is
still like the [ __ ] Mongol cuz my friend
Domitian trips in Mongolia
he like [ __ ] like horse milk biscuits
he had that horse liquor what a Wow and
he threw up oh nice to see what you
showed me a video course I know whenever
you guys are eating it and I walked into
a restaurant honestly
no good I can't eat and they already
gave a service so I was like oh but did
you know it was horse like did you walk
in and go well I eat some barbecue and I
figured it out because I looked at the
chart you know where they show the cuts
of meat wasn't [ __ ] horse cow is
hella skinny dude so you thought you're
walking in a Japanese barbecue yeah
they brought out the platter to it like
the Romney oh the robit was and then
like they would place each part of the
horse on the actual horse plate are like
that's pretty cool so like the my
favorite part was was the there was meat
from the head on in China it was
delicious
yeah I'm chill but you would like it
would I you do it 100% I think it tastes
better than beef
I'm wearing a [ __ ] I'm wearing a
horse Jersey right now man I'm not
grossed out it's like I don't want to
like it too much it's like crack mm
how's that crack do it more because I'm
afraid I'll like it too much
you can't even get in here so I think
you'll be good here that's illegal in
the US okay Pro I didn't like whale meat
as much well that's [ __ ] weird isn't
it yeah it's really bloody the texture
seems worse you guys get the whale meat
Japan Oh
the whale is [ __ ] weird I don't like
that what kind of whale was I don't know
what kind of whale is but imagine yeah
like baby blue whale baby Orca yeah
right yeah it's it's it's the texture of
fish but it's bloody as [ __ ] and it
tastes like iron like a [ __ ] chunk of
brick is it wrong it was it was like
well sashimi that was we like that our
last story there do you guys remember
when Obama went to Vietnam no back in
2016 no all in 2016 I uh I was thinking
about 2015 and a half yeah I remember
one use on Bear Grylls he was
I'm Bear Grylls who are they doing I
don't [ __ ] around what good time yeah
yes so he was in Vietnam back in 2016
and that's when Anthony Bourdain decided
to take Obama out to just a
working-class type of restaurant and
have a meal here so this restaurant so
here's some photos of oh I saw this
picture does he ever wear relaxed
clothing come Jesus are you still the
president at that time you know that is
supposed to be relaxed for a president
yeah yeah no tie rolled up
look at this shitty chairs man I hate I
hate bad chairs in restaurants I hate it
those chairs are buying me on the
freakin preschool chairs
you're supposed to shower in those
chairs do what is right it looks like a
shower stool Asian countries all had
these [ __ ] tiny ass little think it's
cuz they want you to even get the [ __ ]
out they do that they need more traffic
right also I big it's just because
that's a oversized chair for people in
Asia
you ever try to eat in Chipotle like you
get your food you sit down it's the
worst seat of your life oh yeah it's not
comforted so get the hell out of here
it's like having those [ __ ] ledges
for pigeons with their spikes on it so
they actually preserved the seat and a
table and utensils of everything that
Obama's lost height they didn't even
wash it as dirty it looks like they did
this one it's just the one day touched
yeah and they created a combo Obama
which is everything I ordered Oh fried
crab rolls so delicious mm-hmm that's
what the order the whole thing
apparently fried seafood roll bunch ah
grilled pork noodle I'll take the fried
seafood roll and the ride grapples with
bear you know I mean is this a bee sting
or are we gonna skin this [ __ ] like all
that [ __ ] you know guys wearing the same
thing he's wearing full suit and stuff
what are you doing
I still forget that I've never seen him
in a t-shirt there's one picture of him
playing basketball he just went like a
t-shirt it like I want to see him in an
oversized t-shirt some shorts some
sandals like relax yeah well I want to
see him dressing
like Hawaiian style there you go
Hawaiian shirt yeah yeah anything Tommy
Bahama I'm into I love that [ __ ] you see
those pictures of is how he aged like
throughout the presidency yeah he looks
like that so Marlon way I said he look
like Morgan Freeman you know people
always do this [ __ ] doors like look at
the stress on this man right right they
did it to George w they did it to
everybody who's been President Clinton
and I'm always like yeah these guys
always become president like from 40 to
50 like that's when you [ __ ] get the
greatest hair
no [ __ ] City USA it's also almost been
10 years yeah was he young as hell when
he became president when you're
president you have no boss I thought it
was thinking his early 40s all this [ __ ]
about like oh it's the most stressful
job in the world I think it's such a me
into I think I think these guys can kick
it anywhere they want anytime they want
they just get on a plane go wherever
they want that's true give me a break
there's a reason why all everybody runs
again if it's the most stressful job in
the world nobody can handle it that's
true if it was that stress I don't be
like forget it right yeah give me a
brick everyone's [ __ ] and pissing
blood and I know like I want this job
for another four years
give me a break probably cushy [ __ ] ever
there's a reason why people spend
millions and millions of dollars even a
billion dollars to try to run for this
is like Trump you doesn't even stay
inside the White House right because
it's such a piece of [ __ ] yeah sure wait
he was here recently
dude I was on the freeway and he passed
me what the whole car the other night I
was I was headed to the CBB show and I
was we were all stopped in there on the
freeway and then the motorcade went by
the whole perfil dude when they said the
president was coming I still think it's
Obama so there's dope oh yeah yeah yeah
and then I remember that it's chomp and
I'm like this is real life like you
really he's America's first full
president